what turns an undead into a hollow is it
the passing centuries in a never-ending
life the experience of dying hundreds of
times or is it those things
coupled with the loss of hope file link
is often the last place the heroes visit
before they Hollow it's the Gateway to
many dangerous places most Undead in
Lordran have a purpose that they strive
towards before hollowing however there
is one who is content to wait until his
sanity slips away the apathy of this man
is kept within filing shrine where he
simply watches heroes come and go some
never return and he remains at least
nothing will bother him once he goes
hollow I did you see him
big hat Logan the legendary sorcerer in
the flesh this place is simply mad
legendary heroes popped up left and
right they're making me feel quite
inadequate to be honest Oh have you seen
that terribly morose lass the fire
keeper she stuck keeping that bonfire
lit sad really
she's mutant bound to this forsaken
place how did that silly Sorcerer's
Apprentice end up you know the one
always prattling on about master Logan
he left for the undead burg but never
came back serves him right if even
though big hat can't make it out there
what chance does evil I hope he enjoys
his new life as a hollow how did that
raggedy old charm end up you know the
one who idolized some godmother of
pyromancy he left for blight town but
never came back did you hear about the
maiden
virtuous last came back alone and in
absurd new tatters did her followers die
or was she abandoned who knows but I
suppose we've heard the last from m'lady
did you ring the second Bell
that is incredible I must say but now we
have a new problem it's noisy it's Norse
and its breath is lethal and I was
really beginning to like it here oh
maybe it's time I do something about it
well what are you going to do I've
already decided I don't really care
I'm simply crestfallen
you